bonjour jean claude allard merci d'être
avec nous sur rt france vous avez signé
cette tribune
pourquoi le texte dénonce je cite une
perte d'indépendance stratégique qu'est
ce que ça signifie
oui d'abord bon show merci merci de
cette possibilité de d'expliquer je
recommence
oui l'idée centrale de notre texte est
quand même qu'il faut examiner notre
relation avec la russie est donc
réexaminer nos relations avec la russie
a pour conséquence positive ou négative
de devoir également régler aminé à notre
relation avec les états unis
conséquence positive si les états unis
veulent comme parfois le président
emprunt plats avançait aussi retendre la
main à la russie pour construire
ensemble les plus chaudes
à ce moment là la conséquence est
positive et si les états unis ray
résistant à construire quelque chose
avec nous avec leurs outils là cette
conséquence de est négative et dans les
deux cas vous voyez bien que il faut une
autre idée c'est de régler entre 30 et
10 par rapport à la russie avec les
conséquences sur les états unis
ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire être
moins attentiste être plus pro russe
c'est être plus proactive pour
réexaminer
je ne sais pas si au fond de ce
cheminement
on se rapproche mais bon nécessairement
on voit bien que aujourd'hui l'occident
si je puis dire est en relations tendues
avec moscou et que l'idée est bien
entendu d'examiner s'il y a toujours
lieu d'avoir et de de2 de maintenir
cette tension et d'examiner de quelle
façon on peut pour nous français en tant
qu'européen
un recompte re-proposer henry libre âge
entre les différentes puissant on sait
que nous avons d'un côté la chine
on sait que nous avons d'un côté de
l'autre côté les états unis indiscutable
au milieu il y à l'union européenne
l'union européenne à ce qu'on peut pour
quoi elle veut bien la voir et en europe
il ya la russie donc il faut examiner
comment la russie d'intel et amplifie ce
deux poids de l'union européenne cette
tribune a été ratifié par dix
signataires à la retraite on sait qu'il
ya le devoir de réserve chez les
militaires mais selon vous votre point
de vue est ce qu'il est partagé par
l'ensemble des hauts gradés de l'armée
française de côté je n'ai pas fait de et
je n'ai aucune idée et aucune qualité à
répondre d'une façon ou d'une autre à
cette question j'observe siens seulement
que le devoir de réserve s'exprime par
rapport à quelque chose que l'on sait de
ce qui se passe dans l'administration
nous nous sommes hors de cette nécessité
du devoir de réseaux puisque nous
exprimons simplement une opinion des
citoyens sur la halle et relatant est un
macho mal et la façon une des façons
disons de marcher vers une plus grande
intégration enfin le plus grande
efficacité d'union européenne et la
création d'un véritable espace européen
autonome souverain capable de tenir sa
position comme je vous dis entre la
chine et les états unis vous contestez
la présence de la france dans ce
prochain exercice de l'otan defender
l'alliance atlantique on le sait a vu le
jour au temps de la guerre froide
quel est son rôle maintenant est ce que
l'ennemi c'est toujours la russie ou
bien plutôt les affaires du
contreterrorisme voir la chine
alors outre mesure et bien que fait
affaire de défendeur 2020 et simplement
le prétexte sur lequel on peut trois
projets pour expliquer de façon plus
large
cette nécessité de réexaminer nos
rapports avec la russie
donc ils pètent exercices se déroulent à
la frontière est de devait se dérouler à
la frontière reste de l'union européenne
avec nos ennemis désignés les rouges de
l'autre côté nous disons que cette mise
en avant un militaire d'un certain
nombre de mesures devrait être plus
mesuré dans ce tas
la présentation d'abord il qu'on
présente l'ennemi comme étant la russie
si vous voulez assez explicitement on
pense on peut gamine et où pour cet
exemple de l'utilisation de l'armé
nucléaire
donc ce qui paraît à tchité beaucoup et
de grande agitation à la frontière d'un
pays y est depuis une quinzaine d'années
mis à l'écart et soumis à des temps etc
et donc c'est plus une aggravation de
coude c'est un peu une recherche
d'apaisement et de dialogue et
d'ouverture de dialogue
on sait que dernièrement
emmanuel macron s'était exprimé en
souvient notamment du discours du
président de la république face aux
diplomates français
il avait appelé de ses voeux justement
se rapprocher aurait examiné comme vous
dites les liens avec la russie dans les
faits où est-ce qu'on en est mon l'ailé
je pense que cet examen des liens avec
la russie a pris un peu de retard
notamment à cause du cette pandémie et a
mobilisé toutes les forces politiques
dans de nombreux pays y compris dans
ycompris dans le nôtre cette pandémie a
aussi eu un résultat un peu positif pour
nous c'est que elle a mis un peu en
veilleuse cette danse non à la frontière
et surtout elle a l'obligent les pays à
se re considère et l'ensemble de
l'equilibre des relations
internationales de ceux interrogés sur
cette fameuse notion de souveraineté
c'est à dire où sont les intérêts de
chacun des pays et comment il doit les
défendre
voilà et donc je pense que il ya aussi
un autre événement est passée un peu il
désormais passé lui a fait oublier
c'est la question de la succession de
comptines en russie je voyais et deux
cas de figure où patois poutine s'en
aller en 2024 soit il restait donc
maintenant il a ni en plein
vraisemblablement le référendum le le
toit les confirmant la possibilité
d'avoir son mandat étendu cas 2036 mais
mes dents de nantes dans les deux cas il
faut il faut parler alors il faut parler
si samba c'est pour éviter que après son
départ interviennent de chaos dans la
lutte pour le pouvoir et être prêt à
dialoguer avec les différentes parties
pour les ramener à la raison
et si poutine reste c'est construire
avec les uns à venir faire de 1038 pas
fait beaucoup de d'espacés et on peut
quand même pas
considéré que cette opposition russe
contre le reste de l'europe doit
continuer or ceci est bien entendu doit
se faire de façon plus large mais
peut-être que vous avez posé la question
avec nos amis européens
merci merci jean codes de l'art d'avoir
répondu à nos questions je rappelle que
vous êtes général et membre du cercle de
réflexion interarmées